die Wirtschaftsvertreter warnen
eindringlich alle verfügbaren
Energieträger der drk-präsident hält es
für notwendig ich wiederhole für
notwendig alle drei Kernkraftwerke auch
über den April hinaus weiterlaufen zu
lassen der Chef der Verbandes der
chemischen Industrie sagt dass das Gas
embargo ein Herzinfarkt für die deutsche
Wirtschaft ist ich könnte weiter
ausführen was also die
Wirtschaftsvertreter hier sagen aber
eins ist klar die Lage ist ernst die
Bürger werden von den Kostensteigerungen
erdrückt die Pleitewelle ist längst
angelaufen die Unternehmen verlieren das
Vertrauen in eine Zukunft in Deutschland
sie verlagern die Produktion ins Ausland
es lohnt sich leider schlichtweg nicht
mehr in Deutschland zu produzieren
wie können wir das ändern ganz einfach
indem wir das Angebot erhöhen also
Renaissance der Kernenergie nicht nur im
nachzügenerland hier Deutschland
insgesamt sehen wir dass das überall
weltweit passiert und nicht nur für die
drei verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke sondern
insgesamt für alle Kernkraftwerke die
verfügbar sind und eben nicht nur bis
zum März sondern eben darüber hinaus
unbefristet dann muss die Kohle ans Netz
vor allem Braunkohle kann hier einen
hohen Beitrag leisten und wir brauchen
alle Ressourcen zu Belieferung mit Gas
ja auch die russischen müssen genutzt
werden in Pakistan zum Beispiel herrscht
aktuell Energiemangel wir kaufen denen
gerade das lng-gas weg
unsere selbstverletzende Politik hat
eben nicht nur Auswirkungen auf uns hier
nein die Bundesregierung ist mit ihrer
Verknappung der Ressourcen
mitverantwortlich dass die Energiearmut
auch erniedrig entwickelten Ländern
verstärkt wird und die grüne Politik der
Ampel ist für diese Länder nicht nur
dumm und wohlstandszerstören wie bei uns
nein sie ist dort nämlich dann
gefährlich unmoralisch und
neokolonialistisch meine Damen und
Herren
und dann kommen eben solche
irrengeschichten dass wir also diesen
Kohleausstieg jetzt Vorziehen von 2038
via mal gesagt worden ist wir mal
durchaus mit Diskussionen gesagt worden
ist aber jetzt ohne Diskussion 2038
steht im Raum und ja ist völlig klar
dass uns das nicht weiterbringt im
Gegenteil das wird noch weiter den Ast
absägen auf dem wir sitzen und die
Folgen sind eben auch verheerend das
Leibniz-Institut Wirtschaftsforschung in
Halle sieht die Anzahl der Insolvenzen
in September um mehr als 34 Prozent
gestiegen gegenüber dem Vorjahr für den
November sind eben die 40 Prozent leider
prognostiziert
zu Recht wirft man Putin vor den
Mittelstand nicht zu fördern doch hier
passiert genau das gleiche gerade der
Mittelstand erstickt unter den hohen
Energiepreisen und der Antrieb einer
solchen beschädigenden Politik ist der
Gleiche nämlich die Wirtschaft lenken zu
wollen das geht eben nicht mit einem
Mittelständler der nahmen Kunden und
einer Gesellschaft ist das geht aber
durchaus mit Großunternehmen deren
Manager mit der Politik verflochten sind
an einigen Stellen ja sogar verfilzt und
wie leicht die Planwirtschaft einer
Bundesregierung es hatten unsere
weltweit führende Dieseltechnologie zu
beschädigen einzustampfen das ist eben
ein Beleg dafür mit einem gesunden und
seinen Mitarbeitern und der Gesellschaft
verpflichtet Mittelstand ginge das nicht
so leicht meine Damen und Herren
und ja meine Damen und Herren also wir
erleben hier
morgentauplanmäßige Züge die nehmen
leider Schritt für Schritt Forman nur
dass es eben nicht die gesamte Industrie
betrifft sondern nur den
energieintensiven Bereich und eben den
Mittelstand
und
die Beschädigung unserer
energieversorgungs wird immer gesagt
wäre sozialverträglich also legt man
dann Fond auf oder sagt ja das wird
alles sozialverträglich nämlich mit
Umverteilung
aber heute hören wir dass die erste
Kindertagesstätte hier in Deutschland
sagt sie kann ihren Winterbetrieb nicht
mehr leisten sie stellt also den Betrieb
ein eine Kindertagesstätte das heißt
diese unsoziale Politik die geht zu
Lasten unserer Kinder das ist mitnichten
sozial das ist hochgradig unsozial meine
Damen und Herren
und wo soll Gas und Strom denn herkommen
das völlig unklar Gasspeicher sind
gefüllt angeblich ein Kriterium das ist
uns da gut geht aber mitnichten ist all
dieses Gas für uns sondern die das geht
auch noch ins unklar also geht auch noch
ins Ausland ist völlig unklar wie wir
damit umgehen und völlig unklar ist auch
wie es zum Beispiel PC-Karte zum Schwedt
weitergeht auch hier nur
Absichtserklärung leere Worte nein meine
Damen und Herren diese Politik der
Bundesregierung ist eine sozialistische
verbotskultur die Bundesregierung
sollten wir Zentralkomitee der
Einheitspartei nennen das wäre ehrlicher
Steffen Portrait hat hier diese aktuelle
Stunde begonnen 5 Minuten und da geht es
nicht
der Kunden überzieht ich bitte Yvonne
mag was erinnert hier noch mal an die
Redezeit in einer aktuellen Stunde haben
alle Abgeordneten genau fünf Minuten
Redezeit und werden auch mit so einigen
Signalen darauf hingewiesen wenn diese
fünf Minuten um sind allerdings halten
sich nicht unbedingt alle Abgeordneten
immer da dran Markus hümpfer spricht
jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich kann
ganz gut verstehen dass es eine Aktuelle
Stunde zu diesem Thema gibt die Menschen
wollen wissen wie es wirklich um die
Energieversorgung in unserem Land steht
aber das ausgerechnet sie sich um die
Energieversorgung in unserem Land
Scheren das habe ich bisher noch nicht
mitbekommen
stattdessen stattdessen halten sie in
jeder Rede die Atomkraft hoch das Thema
hat sich doch schon lange erledigt Isa 2
Neckarwestheim zwei Emsland gehen in den
streckbetrieb das dienender
Versorgungssicherheit davon profitieren
vor allem die Bundesländer die in der
Vergangenheit wenig erneuerbare Energien
ausgebaut haben Bayern zum Beispiel und
dann wollen sie ja sogar noch die
Atomkraft verlängern sie wollen ja sogar
neue Kernkraftwerke bauen aber wo kommen
denn das Uran dafür her
sie kennen die Antwort und selbst wenn
sie das Uran haben die Herstellung von
Brennstäben dauert bis zu zwölf Monaten
meistens länger das ist doch keine
Lösung für diesen Winter und auch nicht
für den nächsten das müssen sie doch das
müssen sie doch langsam mal verstanden
haben und dann haben wir immer noch das
Problem mit dem Atommüll wo soll der
denn hin sollen wir denn auf den Mond
schießen
Bayern will den Müll auf jeden Fall
nicht aber dafür die Atomkraft das
widerspricht sich ein bisschen sie
finden kein Bundesland das diesen
Atommüll freiwillig nimmt aber
vielleicht schlagen sie da
endlagersuchkommission ja mal ihre
Vorgärten vor
dann dann das erdgasthema sie wollen
Tracking ausbauen konventionell und
unkonventionell fangen wir mal mit dem
konventionellen Fracking an also
normaler Erdgasförderung wir haben 2021
5,2 Milliarden Kubikmeter Erdgas in
Deutschland gefördert wir verbrauchen
aber 100 Milliarden Kubikmeter Erdgas
jedes Jahr unsere
erdgasvorkommend sind so klein da lohnen
sie sich gar nicht die weiter zu
erschließen da würden sie nur Geld
verbrennen aber Wirtschaftskompetenz
haben sie ja nicht
jetzt zum jetzt zum unkonventionellen
Fracking dabei wenn mit Hilfe von Druck
und Flüssigkeiten gesteinschichten
aufgespalten
um gebundenes Erdgas freizusetzen
Flüssigkeiten die nicht ohne Sinn die
enthalten stark wassergefährdende
krebserregende und Hormon verändernde
Toxine das ist pure Chemie das will
niemand bei sich in der Nähe haben diese
Flüssigkeiten können ins Grundwasser
eindringen das verpestet unser kostbares
Grundwasser und davon haben wir sowieso
schon so wenig was wollen sie den
Menschen eigentlich noch alles zumuten
in diesem Land sollen die für ein
bisschen Erdgas jetzt giftiges Wasser
trinken
deshalb ist es gut dass diese Koalition
das Land durch diese schwere Krise führt
wir haben wir haben bereits das
Energieangebot konsequent ausgeweitet
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die
Versorgungssicherheit sichergestellt ist
wir haben wir haben zwölf
Kohlekraftwerke mit einer Leistung von 7
Gigawatt ans Netz genommen trotz
Kohleausstieg weil wir nicht zwischen
Politik und Idealismus unterscheiden
anders als Sie
Isa 2 Neckarwestheim zwei Emsland das
sind drei Atomkraftwerke mit einer
Leistung von 4,5 Gigawatt wir haben
ermöglicht dass unsere Biogasanlagen
kurzfristig mehr Gas und Strom
produzieren können das sind sieben
Terawattstunden Strom das entspricht dem
Verbrauch von zwei Millionen Haushalten
wir haben schon im osterpaket den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien deutlich
beschleunigt
Windkraftanlagen PV Wasserkraft wir
haben auch den Netzausbau beschleunigt
das schafft Versorgungssicherheit vor
allem für den Süden Deutschlands
wir bauen lng-terminals Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel Stade Lubmin das macht uns
unabhängig und
ja und das haben wir beschlossen weit
bevor sie auf die Idee gekommen sind
heute eine Aktuelle Stunde zu diesem
Thema zu beantragen diese Koalition
handelt entschieden wir sichern die
Versorgungssicherheit von Deutschland
vielen Dank
Markus Hüpfer war das
CSU hatte für die SPD-Fraktion für die
Unionsfraktion spricht jetzt ihr
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
Jens Spahn
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu Beginn ein paar Worte zu der
Fraktion die diese aktuelle Stunde
beantragt hat sie wollen Wut und
Unzufriedenheit führen sie sind
wutschführer das ist ihr Geschäftsmodell
sie wollen dass es diesem Land möglichst
schlecht geht wie sie ja mittlerweile
ganz offen zugeben in der Hoffnung davon
zu profitieren sie sind die fünfte
Kolonne Putins mit den Reden die sie
hier halten und der Portrait hat ja
geradezu ich meine sonst sehr Portrait
hören wir hier ja noch ganz andere Töne
von ihnen sie wollen Deutschland und
Europa nicht rausführen aus der
Abhängigkeit von Russland sie wollen uns
sogar weiter reinführen sie für sie
schwenken auf ihren Demonstrationen
russische Fahnen sie sind eine
destruktive Opposition und all das was
sie tun hat Patriotismus nichts zu tun
sie schaden diesem Land mit dem wie sie
die Debatten führen
wir als
oppositionsparteiunion wollen dass es
unserem Land gut geht das ist gut durch
diese Krise kurz und wir unterstützen
dabei die Regierung wenn Sie das
Richtige tut um durch diese Krise zu
kommen das haben wir in den letzten
Monaten auch gezeigt wenn wir auch
vielen ihrer Gesetze zugestimmt haben
und auch das Herr Kollege gremmels sei
gesagt unsere Hand ist weiterhin
ausgestreckt zu Zusammenarbeit nur gab
es bis heute übrigens in den letzten
acht Monaten nicht ein Angebot zum
Gespräch das ist okay sie haben die
Mehrheit aber am Ende des Tages wenn Sie
hier immer einfordern konstruktiv zu
sein sollten Sie vielleicht gelegentlich
das Gespräch suchen und nicht nur
schreien
und das eigentliche Problem ist ja ein
anderes das ampelbild der letzten Wochen
ist fatal zu oft zögern Zaudern zoffen
nicht mal klar welchen Teil der
Ampelmann denn überhaupt unterstützen
sollte den Wirtschaftsminister oder den
Finanzminister in keiner Frage Einigkeit
es geht zu weniger genau es geht zu
wenig um die eigentliche Sachfrage worum
geht es nämlich eine sichere und
bezahlbare
es geht um eine sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung für unser Land und um
gezielte Entlastungen für Unternehmen
und Bürgerinnen und Bürger und nach dem
sogenannten Machtwort des Kanzlers das
scheint ja für die Koalition ein großer
Schritt ein Kraftakt zu sein für
Deutschland ist es in Wahrheit ein
minischritt ein Schrittchen
denn auf dem Weg zur Stromproblem zu
lösen bringt uns das nur klein wenig
weiter Bundesminister Bundesminister
Harbeck sagt der könne gut blöd Leben
mit diesem Kompromiss das ist aber nicht
der Maßstab es geht nicht darum ob er
Harbeck oder die Grünen damit leben
können es geht darum ob es Deutschland
gut durch diese Krise bringt und dafür
reicht es nicht
es ist notwendig es ist notwendig alle
energieerzeugungen zu nutzen die wir
haben es muss notwendig dass alles was
ohne Erdgas Strom produzieren kann ans
Netz geht und ja auch nachdem wir es ja
mehrfach hier vorgeschlagen haben und da
haben wir übrigens dann auch zugestimmt
einiges ist passiert Biogas Sonne Wind
bei der Kohle bisher sind nur zwei
Steinkohlekraftwerke zusätzlich am Netz
dagegen mehr aber es geht dem auch um
die Kernkraft und Sie verlieren da
weiter Zeit in dieser Woche wird es
keine erste Lesung geben es gibt keinen
Gesetzentwurf hier im Deutschen
Bundestag den wir beraten und die
Bundesregierung sagt selbst die
Bundesregierung sagt selbst sie sagen
selbst der zweite Winter wird
wahrscheinlich härter werden für uns
auch in Fragen der Energiesicherheit als
der erste Winter schon geworden ist und
deswegen sollten diese Kernkraftwerke
bis mindestens Ende 2024 laufen wir
sollten neue Brennelemente bestellen
niemand der irgendwie mit Vernunft auf
das Problem schaut und auf die mögliche
Lösung kann zu einem anderen Ergebnis
kommen und deswegen wenn Sie sich jetzt
schon deswegen bewegen sie sich richtig
um Deutschland gut durch diese nächsten
zwei winterzuführen
was ich sowieso nicht verstehen werde
auch in den Diskussionen sie lassen
lieber Klimakiller Kohle und lieber
ölkraftwerke auf Schiffen mit Schweröl
laufen als klimaneutrale sichere
Kernkraftwerke bitte erzählen Sie uns
nichts von Klimaschutz wenn ihnen ein
Kraftwerk Kohlekraftwerk aus DDR-Zeiten
eines der ältesten Kohlekraftwerke die
in Europa stehen die bringen sie
irgendwie gerne und die nächsten zwei
Jahre ans Netz da geht Blei Quecksilber
Kupfer und Arsen in die Luft das sind
die Emissionen sie lassen lieber den
Klimakiller Kohle und die ältesten
Kohlekraftwerke in Deutschland ans Netz
als sichere verlässliche Kernkraftwerke
und deswegen erzählen sie uns nichts von
Klimaschutz in diesen Zeiten und in
dieser Krise
und was für die energiegesicherheit gilt
gilt auch für die Entlastung ein
doppelwumms eher die Sprache der Kirmes
als die eines Kanzlers nun ja aber ein
doppelwumms war angekündigt aber wer ist
nun damit vor sechs Wochen das dritte
Entlastungspaket angekündigt vor drei
Wochen ein Abwehrschirm angekündigt vor
eineinhalb Wochen hat die gaskommission
Vorschläge gemacht und wir wissen immer
noch nicht was davon Sie wann umsetzen
wollen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Unternehmen Mittelstand Handwerk machen
sich Gedanken wie sie ihre Strom und
Gasrechnung in diesem Winter bezahlen
sollen sie haben bis jetzt nichts davon
entschieden keine Perspektive gegeben
und solange sie das nicht tun machen sie
es den vereinfachern von links und
rechts so einfach und deswegen
entscheiden sie endlich das gibt dem
Land Zuversicht und Zusammenhalt
Jens Spahn war das fünf Minuten wenn sie
in übrigens morgen noch einmal hören
wollen mit seiner Sicht auf die
europäische Energieversorgung da ist er
ab 8:45 Uhr mit Matthias Mirsch bei uns
im Interview bei Phoenix Bernhard
Herrmann jetzt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
ist ermittelt sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
Herr Spahn wir haben uns schon wieder
unterhalten jetzt hier die ganze Runde
auch zu fünf Prozent der Lösungsoptionen
zu Versorgungssicherheit darum geht es
nämlich und wir haben damit 95% der Zeit
wieder verschwendet das werde ich nicht
fortsetzen
vorgebliche Uneinigkeit so ist auch der
Titel dieses Antrags der AFD gewesen in
der Koalition beklagt ausgerechnet diese
AFD ja unterschiedliche Auffassung
gehören nun mal zu Demokratie so ist das
und ja so wird auch innerhalb unserer
Koalition um gute Lösungen gerungen das
mag der AFD Respekt sein schließlich
werden dort ja Auseinandersetzung meist
nicht inhaltlich ausgetragen dieser
streiten sich immer wieder persönlich
verschleißend seit ihrer Gründung einmal
Parteivorsitzenden nach dem anderen
schrumpfen regelmäßig ihre Fraktion auf
allen Ebenen Einigkeit der AFD wohl kaum
mit der Sache aber beschäftigt sich die
AFD so gut wie nie denn sonst hätten sie
ja gemerkt dass Atomkraftwerke eben
nicht verlässlich zur Versorgung oder
gar deren Sicherheit beitragen
stattdessen ist das Desaster der
westeuropäischen Atomkraftwerke neben
der Verknappung beim Gas durch den
Angriffskrieg Putins das maßgebliche
Problem für die vernetzte europäische
Stromversorgung die zum Glück vernetzt
ist und nicht national heute vor zwei
Stunden waren ganze 44 Prozent der
französischen AKW Leistung am Netz
zuverlässig nein dass sie ja anders aus
sie hätten gemerkt dass es die Ampel
trotz der Einstellung der Gaslieferungen
aus Russland geschafft hat dass die
Gasspeicher jetzt schon zu fast 100%
gefüllt sind und so auch die Preise für
den gasimport sinken schauen Sie mal hin
es geht voran
die sie hätten gemerkt dass die
Koalition 200 Milliarden Euro aus dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds
bereitstellen wird um niemanden wegen
hoher Wärme und Strompreise
zahlungsunfähig werden zu lassen keine
Menschen keine Mittelstandsunternehmen
und auch keine Industrieunternehmen sie
hätten gemerkt dass wir auch im nötigen
Maß aber mit klugerentscheidung auch
Kohlekraftwerke vorübergehend ans Netz
nehmen dafür aber denn der Klimawandel
wartet nicht dass aus der
Kohleverstromung bis 2030 ansteuern das
bmwk
hat inzwischen mehr als 50 Gesetze uns
Verordnung auf dem Weg gebracht die
allesamt nötig sind um möglichst
unbeschadet durch die jetzige Situation
zu kommen wir stärken die
Energieeffizienz und bauen die
Erneuerbaren massiv aus sowie noch nie
leider hat Herr März heute morgen
wirklich in Deutschlandfunk so getan als
wenn es wieder alles nicht ginge er
wünscht sich das ausbremsen durch die
AKWs der Windenergie ganz klar der
ansätzende Boom bei der Photovoltaik ist
beeindruckend und wird zurzeit nur
ausgebremst durch mangelnde Technik
Verfügbarkeit und Installateure kein
Wunder bei 10 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
Strom selbst erzeugt und selbst
verbraucht ein ganz geniale Sache
steuerlich absolut vereinfacht gemeinsam
von gelben Finanzministerium und Grünen
Wirtschaftsministerium auf den Weg
gebracht eine ganz gewaltige
Verbesserung so erfolgreich dass selbst
die Partei am rechten Rand oder bei
denen einige ab und zu vom Solarstrom
schwärmen um dann aber wieder kurz
danach das Ende der Energiewende
auszurufen wie passt das zusammen
natürlich gar nicht aber postfaktikern
ist das doch egal
was also ist mit Uneinigkeit in diesem
Antrag gemeint ja in der Tat kam das
klare Bekenntnis das nötige Geld in die
Hand zu nehmen dass Menschen und
Unternehmen ihre Energierechnungen
bezahlen können reichlich spät es ist
absolut richtig wie Robert Habeck schon
immer gesagt hat Vernachlässigungen von
Investitionen in der Realität in Bildung
Infrastrukturen Klimaschutz und sozialem
sind genauso schädlich wie Schulden in
den Büchern Gesellschaft ja Zusammenhalt
und unsere zu erhaltenen
Wirtschaftsstrukturen sind knallharte
Realität
und daher Dank auch da an den
Finanzminister das nun hier muss ich
aber sagen endlich das Geld da ist im
Haushalt und Unternehmen zu entlasten
und Dank vor allem an Menschen
Unternehmen Stadtwerke bei mir in
Sachsen die mich mit meinen Forderungen
genau danach in den letzten Monaten auch
schriftlich immer stärker unterstützt
haben oder meint die AFD den Umgang mit
den AKWs da wurde schon wieder so viel
geredet drüber dass die drei
ampelparteien hier unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen haben ist doch nur
bekannt wir Grünen haben die Notreserve
für zwei AKWs vorgeschlagen die es bei
der mangelage im Süden nah an Frankreich
wirklich brauchen kann und wir stellen
sicher dass die AKWs gut vorbereitet
sind damit sie auch durch den Winter
wirklich kommen und nicht der
Profitmaximierung dienen für den Einsatz
der AKWs des akw-emsland sehe ich aber
keinen Grund keinen fachlichen Grund
viel mehr twittert ein SPD-Kollege dass
so die Windräder im Norden ausgebremst
werden schon jetzt müssten jährlich fünf
Terawattstunden Windstrom abgeregelt
werden aber in der Debatte mit Ihnen
liebe Kolleginnen der demokratischen
Parteien
auch deutlich wir waren immer ein
Mindestmaß an Sachlichkeit an
sachorientierung unterscheiden uns damit
von denen die in Wirklichkeit den
Schaden fürs Land wünschen wenn ich voll
bei Ihnen ersparen weil das deren
politisches Geschäftsmodell ist
wir werden nun konkret
die finanziellen Entlastung auf dem Weg
bringen sehr schnell bei Gas und Wärme
insgesamt und etwas komplizierter ist
das das müssen wir ein Menschen auch
sehr ehrlich sagen damit es keine Brüche
gibt beim Strom aber auch dort werden
wir liefern noch dieses Jahr und
rückwirkend für 22 massiv entlasten
bitte schließen wir dazu die rein unter
uns Demokraten bei aller berechtigten
und manchmal auch nötigen Uneinigkeit in
der Sache das gehört zu Demokratie
herzlichen Dank
sagt Bernhard Herrmann aus der Fraktion
der Grünen hier im Bundestag Ralf
lenkert ist der nächste Sprecher und er
ist Sprecher für Umweltpolitik Energie
und Klimaschutz der Linksfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es nervt schon
wieder reden wir über Atomkraft und an
die AFD in jeder Ehe gibt es
Meinungsverschiedenheiten zumindest wenn
man anders als sie Gleichberechtigung
ernst nimmt ich habe Verständnis wenn
Koalitionspartner unterschiedliche
Positionen vertreten auch wenn ich in
diesem Fall das Festhalten an Atomkraft
blödsinnig finde aber es nervt dass die
AFD einen erledigten Koalitionsstreit
erneut anfachen will nur um sich zu
profilieren wir haben hier wirklich
wichtigere Themen zu bearbeiten aber
nein dann drehen wir halt die hundertste
extrahunde und kauen erneut durch warum
Atomkraft Schwachsinn ist erstens
Atomkraft ist hoch riskant geht was
schief dann war es das zweitens Atome
will keiner haben niemand will ihn
Lagern er strahlt hunderttausende Jahre
und der Irre Glaube an Transmutation ist
mehr Fiktion als Realität
drittens der Mythos das französische
Atomstrom Deutschland rettet ist seit
diesem Sommer wieder lebt von 56
französischen Atomreaktoren laufen keine
30 raten Sie mal welcher deutsche Strom
Frankreich jetzt vorm Blackout rettet
viertens der von ihnen
ignorierte Klimawandel vereitelt die von
ihnen glorreich verehrte Atomenergie
weil wegen der dürren ausreichend
Kühlwasser fehlen wird so wie diesen
Sommer in Frankreich
fünftens lange Bauzeiten von über 15
Jahren für neue AKW sechstens keine
Versicherung bezahlt Schäden nach Atomen
Fällen 7 ohne Milliarden
Steuersubventionen wäre Atomstrom und
bezahlbar achtens ganze Region werden
durch Uranbergbau zerstört und tausende
Bergleute sterben vorzeitig an Krebs und
neunten ich habe jetzt lang genug über
den Irrweg Atomkraft gesprochen
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
habe Lust mit ihnen an einer
Energieversorgung zu arbeiten die
wirklich risikoarm ist die bezahlbar und
sicher ist und von der die Menschen in
den Regionen profitieren wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass jeder erzeugte
Kilowattstunde auch genutzt wird dafür
schlägt beispielsweise Linke vor den
Ausbau der Wärmenetze und die Nutzung
von Überschussstrom für Wärme dann
stehen Windräder seltener still neue
netzentgelder für Unternehmen es ist
doch Schwachsinn das Unternehmen den
billigsten stromkriegen wenn sie 7000
Stunden lang konstant Strom verbrauchen
ich fordere ein System das Industrie-
und wir fordern regional erzeugten Strom
auch regional in Deutschland zu
verbrauchen dafür sollten in Deutschland
die Preiszonen getrennt werden
Energie ist da seinsvorsorge und muss
bezahlbar sein jeden Tag an der
Tanksäule sieht man das Konzerne stets
versuchen ein Maximum an Profiten
herauszuschlagen wir fordern eine
strenge preisaufsicht die Abzocke und
Spekulation verhindert und die Linke vor
der preisdecke für Strom Gas Fernwärme
und alle anderen heizenergien die
Netzentgelte steigen weil privat
organisierte Netzbetreiber ihren Aufbau
an Gewinnmargen statt am
volkswirtschaftlichen Bedarf
orientierten wir fordern die
Übertragungsnetze in einem Unternehmen
zu verstaatlichen
[Applaus]
die Menschen brauchen preiswerte
grundkontingente für Strom Gas und
Heizenergie und auch Handwerk
Landwirtschaft und Unternehmen benötigen
diese liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
genannten Maßnahmen helfen aber ihre
Umsetzung wird Zeit brauchen deshalb
braucht es wirksame Soforthilfen ab
sofort 120 125 Euro monatlich für jeden
Haushalt das macht 1.500 Euro im Jahr
plus 50 Euro für jede weitere Person
sind nochmal 600 Euro ein
Heizkostenzuschuss zum Wohngeld nach
Haushaltsgröße wir fordern Zuschüsse zu
Energiekosten an Kommunen an
Krankenhäuser Pflegeheime und an alle
Sozialeinrichtungen und zur Bezahlung
können wir 100 Milliarden aus der
extrabesteuerung von Sondergewinn der
Konzerne nehmen und eine Vermögenssteuer
einführen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich muss wiederholen über unsere
Vorschläge Rede und streitig gern mit
Ihnen das wäre produktiv prechte
wirksame Ergebnisse für die Menschen für
die Umwelt für das Klima die
eigentlichen Probleme liegen noch vor
uns es ist der Klimawandel und der
Streit über Atomkraft bremst uns nur aus
vielen Dank
und für die AFD für die FDP-Fraktion hat
das Wort dr Lukas Köhler Entschuldigung
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber
Kollege Spahn sie haben eben gefragt wie
sie unterstützen sollen ich hätte den
Tipps unterstützen doch mal jemanden
Konzept aufschreibt jemanden der Ihnen
mal sagt welche Richtung sie gehen weil
es gab einen Unterschied und das war
erschreckend zu sehen dass Ralf lenkert
von der Linken hier mehr konzeptuell
vorliegt als die Union und das ist weiß
das findet ihr SPD nicht sehr
erschreckend aber mich ehrlicherweise
erschreckt das in dieser Debatte weil
ich finde ich finde es ist eine
Überraschung und die Diskussion um
Netzentgelte und die Zukunft des
Stromsystems zu führen das finde ich
tatsächlich ist jetzt in dieser
Situation geboten denn meine Damen und
Herren klar ist doch wirtschaftliches
Vorankommen Wirtschaftswachstum ich weiß
da hören wir jetzt auf uns einer Meinung
zu sein aber Wirtschaftswachstum hängt
doch davon ab wie wir stabile
verlässliche wirtschaftliche
Rahmenbedingungen setzen und natürlich
ist die Energiepolitik die
Energieversorgung die Netzstabilität die
Preisstabilität einer der zentralen
Bestandteile von wirtschaftlichen
vorankommen und das ist etwas in das wir
jetzt investieren müssen in dass wir
jetzt Gedanken aber auch Finanzmittel
auch Kapital reinstecken müssen und
deswegen haben wir doch in dieser
Bundesregierung mit diesem Parlament
schon so viele hervorragende Dinge
beschlossen wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
die Netze im überragenden öffentlichen
Interesse sind wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass Speicher endlich eine eigene
Definition haben und so viel besser
angereizt werden neben allen anderen
Krisenmaßnahmen räumen wir die großen
Probleme der letzten Jahrzehnte auf und
das ist der richtige Weg der nur das
schafft Verlässlichkeit im Netz wir
müssen darüber nachdenken
wir müssen darüber nachdenken wie
Flexibilität belohnt wird weil die
Zukunft ist doch nicht mehr eine Welt in
der wir von russischem pipeline-gas
abhängig sein dürfen das darf uns nie
wieder passieren
und das bedeutet gleichzeitig wir müssen
jetzt darüber nachdenken wie wir dafür
sorgen können dass in Zukunft andere
Netze an reflexibilitäten aber auch an
andere stromdesign Aussehen aus einer
stromagdesign aussehen kann genauso
müssen wir aber darüber nachdenken wie
sieht die Industrie in der Zukunft auf
eine Industrie die auf einem Gaspreis
aufsetzt der eben sich am LNG am
Weltmarktpreis orientieren wird und das
sind Debatten die wir jetzt führen die
wir jetzt führen müssen auch darüber wie
eine solche
gaspreisbremse wie die Kommission sie
fort und fordert in einem
grundsätzlichen nur in einer
grundsätzlichen Welt in einem nie normal
aussehen wird und das ist exakt die
Diskussion die wir füllen aber das ist
ja nicht nur die Diskussion die wir
jetzt führen wir müssen erstmal über
diesen Winter kommen und deswegen ist es
völlig richtig dass wir über diesen
Winter die Kernkraft weiterlaufen lassen
wir sorgen dafür dass es jetzt alles
dafür getan wird dass wir es hinbekommen
Netzstabilität Preissicherheit
Versorgungssicherheit aufrecht zu
erhalten aber das bedeutet doch auch
dass wir über den nächsten Sommer und
den nächsten Winter nachdenken müssen
dafür haben wir aber eine Menge mehr
Optionen wir haben lng-schiffe der
Gaspreis fällt übrigens gerade
glücklicherweise weil die Speicher voll
sind weil es genügend lng-schiffe auf
der in der Pipeline gibt um angedockt zu
werden der Gaspreis fällt aber auch
deswegen weil wir politisch klar machen
in welche Richtung wir uns bewegen und
das ist Verantwortungsübernahme das sind
Konzepte die wir jetzt umsetzen die wir
weiterbringen aber natürlich hängt auch
der
zukünftige Strompreis davon ab wie
schnell wir mit dem Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien Vorankommen
natürlich ist es ein zentraler
Bestandteil weil etwas mit Grenzkosten
Null also das in der Produktion nichts
kostet ist ökonomisch sinnvoll und das
sehen wir heute das sehen wir an jeder
Stelle das sehen wir übrigens dann wenn
viel Sonne scheint und viel Wind weht
und jetzt müssen wir doch dafür sorgen
dass die Rahmenbedingungen drumherum
aufgebaut sind da braucht es gar keine
Förderung mehr da geht es jetzt darum
dass wir ausreichend Speicher
ausreichend Netze ausreichend
Versorgungskapazitäten aber der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland hängt
von nicht nur von der Energieversorgung
er hängt auch von verlässlichen
Rahmenbedingungen anderer Stelle hat
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
jetzt darüber nachdenken welche
bürokratiemaßnahmen entlastet werden
können und müssen wir müssen die
Produktivität in diesem Land in den
Vordergrund stellen wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir mehr und schneller
produzieren und dass wir an einer
Industriewelt der Zukunft arbeiten und
das ist der Standort den wir wollen das
ist der Standort den weiterentwickeln
werden gemeinsam aber es geht auch darum
wie wir Fachkräfte versorgen würden den
Vordergrund stellen wir fragen mit im
Freihandel Weiterkommen deswegen fand
ich den Vorschlag auch noch mal mit den
USA zu reden aus der SPD großartig wir
unterstützen das sofort es geht aber
auch darum wie wir Menschen
weiterqualifizieren es geht darum dass
wir Menschen entlasten wie wir auch
Menschen in Verantwortung nehmen und
deswegen geht es auch darum dass wir mit
solchen Konzepten wie dem Bürgergeld
weiter vorankommen meine Damen und
Herren wir haben in diesem Land enorm
viel zu tun und wir gehen es an den
unterschiedlichen Stellen an ich glaube
das ist das Wichtige und zwar mit einem
anständigen Konzept und viel
Diskussionsbereitschaft beides freut
mich danke
die
Diskussionsbereitschaft haben glaube ich
alle in der Koalition mitbekommen der
Streit über die verlängerte Laufzeit von
Atomkraftwerken ging ja so weit bis eben
Olaf Scholz von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz Gebrauch gemacht
hat Mark Bernhard spricht nun als
nächstes für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es war einmal ein Land mit sicherer und
bezahlbarer Energie für jedermann
ein Land mit den sichersten
Kernkraftwerken und den saubersten
Kohlekraftwerken der Welt ein Land in
dem niemand frieren oder im Dunkeln
sitzen musste
doch im Jahr 2011 beschloss die
Regierung als einziges Land auf der Welt
aus der sicheren Energieversorgung
auszusteigen die Welt staunte über die
von der Regierung ausgerufene sogenannte
Energiewende
aber nach kurzer Zeit war sich die ganze
Welt einig dass es sich dabei um die
Welt dümmste Energiepolitik handelt
nämlich gleichzeitig aus Kernkraft und
Kohle Energie auszusteigen denn um zu
wissen dass man den Industrieland nicht
mit Wind und Sonne allein betreiben kann
und schon gar nicht für sichere und
bezahlbare energiesorgen kann muss man
wirklich kein Raketenwissenschaftler
sein dennoch machten die Regierung und
ihre nachfolgeregierungen egal ob mit
roter schwarzer gelber oder grüner
Beteiligung trotz aller
wissenschaftlicher evidenz- und
weltweiter Wärme Warnungen in immer
schnelleren Tempo weiter und so dauerte
es keine acht Jahre und es mussten
bereits 7,4 Millionen Menschen im Land
frieren
und es wurde schlimmer nach zehn Jahren
hatten sich die Kosten für Energie so
erhöht dass viele um ihre Wohnungen und
ihre Arbeitsplätze Banken und auf
Almosen vom Staat angewiesen waren
so dass er ähnlich wird man einmal die
Geschichte unseres Landes erzählen wenn
wir nicht sofort und entschieden
gegensteuern
deutschland braucht im Durchschnitt 60
Gigawatt Strom diese Leistung wurde 2011
vollständig durch Kohle und Kernenergie
erzeugt auch wenn es Nacht war und kein
Wind wehte bis heute wurden fast 30
Gigawatt Kohle und Kernenergie also
praktisch die Hälfte davon abgeschaltet
von ihnen und diese können eben nicht
durch Wind und Sonne ersetzt werden weil
auch eine Million Windräder oder
Solaranlagen eben keinen Strom erzeugen
wenn es Nacht ist und kein Wind weht und
das hat ja wohl auch die Regierung
erkannt und deshalb in den letzten
Jahren uns völlig abhängig gemacht von
russischen Gaslieferungen und damit
versucht die verheerenden Auswirkungen
ihrer Politik zu vertuschen da waren ja
sie eine Regierung oder
mit dem Ergebnis
dass wir die höchst mit dem Ergebnis
dass wir heute die höchsten Strompreise
der Welt bezahlen dass die Spritpreise
seit Jahresbeginn um 60% gestiegen sind
und der Gaspreis sich verdreifacht hat
genau die Ursache für diese sogenannte
Energiekrise ist eben gerade nicht der
Ukraine Krieg sondern das größte
regierungsversagen in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und wie unfähig wie unfähig diese
Regierung ist die Energieversorgung der
Menschen schreien sie nur
[Musik]
der Menschen in Deutschland
sicherzustellen hat sie eindeutig
eindrücklich beim Anschlag auf
nordstream 1 und 2 gezeigt zwar war sie
merkwürdig still und tatenlos und an den
plötzlicher Hektik sage und schreibe
drei Wochen später in Untersuchungsteam
loszuschicken dass sein vor Ort
festgestellt hat dass es gar nicht die
notwendige Ausrüstung hat um den
Anschlag überhaupt untersuchen zu können
das zeugt schon von ganz besonderem
aufklärungswillen peinlicher geht es
wirklich nicht mehr
und als Begründung gibt es wirklich nur
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder sie können
oder sie wollen nicht die Menschen mit
ausreichen bezahlbarer Energie versorgen
dabei liegt es einzig und allein bei
Ihnen bringen sie die saubersten
Kohlekraftwerke der Welt wieder ans Netz
nehmen Sie die noch intakte Leitung von
nordstream 2 endlich im Betrieb nutzen
Sie unsere eigenen Gasvorkommen die
können russisches Gas nämlich für die
nächsten 40 Jahre komplett ersetzen
lassen Sie unsere aktiven Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen und nehmen Sie die kürzlich
abgeschalteten wieder in Betrieb machen
sie die weltdümmste Energiewende
rückgängig und schützen sie die deutsche
Energieversorgung endlich wirksam gegen
alle Staatsterroristen und vor allem
kommen sie eher kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss Menschen nach und bringen Sie
alles was Energie erzeugt sofort ans
Netz
Mark bernhard war das von der
afd-fraktion wurde hier viel
unterbrochen von kleinen Zwischenrufen
unter anderem auch von Timon gremmels
aus der SPD der wird hier auch noch als
letzter Redner sprechen jetzt ist aber
erst einmal seine Parteikollegin Nina
Scheer dran die Sprecherin für
Klimaschutz und Energie der SPD-Fraktion
man muss immer erst mal tief durchatmen
wenn man nach der AFD ganz riednerpult
geht weil man sich wirklich
zusammenreißen muss die Redezeit die wir
uns alle hier
sammeln sollten nicht auf stumpf sind zu
verwenden den es hier zu entkräften
gelte aber ich komme zurück oder fange
gleich an mit der Sache also sie wollen
gerne dass hier heute uns in der
Aktuellen Stunde mit einer
erweiterungsenergieangebots
auseinandersetzen und
bringen dann aber nach und nach immer
nur wieder das gleiche vor wie wir sie
auch aus früheren Anträgen kennen dass
sie meinen in der Atomenergie dann eben
die Lösung zu sehen sie wissen genau
dass Sie mit diesen Dingen die sie dann
entwickeln wollen in
Jahrzehnten der Zukunft liegen die
sowieso nicht Energiesicherheit mehr
bringen könnten von den Technologien her
damit es die Infusion angesprochen und
die Dinge die sonst sie die Sie sonst
noch in der Atomenergie entdecken wollen
dann sehen sie eben auch eine
Energiesicherheit die einfach
schlichtweg Fakten basiert nicht gegeben
ist man muss einfach ganz klar
konzertieren dass ein steigender Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien den wir dringend
brauchen sowohl aus
ressourcenpolitischen Gründen als auch
aus Klimaschutzgründen dass dieser
steigende Aufbau erneuerbare Energien
mit Blick auf das strommarktdesign was
man dafür braucht um Blick auf die
Netzinfrastruktur die wir haben und die
wir weiter ausbauen
diese steigenden Mengen erneuerbarer
einen sinkenden Anteil an von fossilen
Energie und natürlich auch Atomenergie
verlangen weil diese beiden Dinge
einfach schlecht zusammenpassen wir
brauchen ein strommarktdesign Lukas
Köhler hat es auch angesprochen und wir
brauchen auch insgesamt ein Stromsystem
und ein Energiesystem nicht nur Strom
ein Energiesystem was auf die
Eigenschaften der erneuerbaren Energien
zugeschnitten ist und mit Eigenschaften
meine ich die fluktuierenden
Eigenschaften natürlich gibt es nicht zu
jeder Minute Wind und nicht zu jeder
Minute Sonne aber es ergänzt sich
teilweise es muss mit Speichern ergänzt
werden und ich muss mit gutem
Netzmanagement ergänzt werden und
viele Speicher haben wir schon sie sind
aber zum Zeit nicht richtig ins Netz zu
bringen weil sie eben blockiert werden
genauso wie auch erneuerbare Energien
blockiert werden und Sie werden eben
auch von Atomenergie blockiert insofern
muss auch konstatiert werden wir haben
jetzt mit
der Entscheidung von Olaf Scholz die
überfällig war die zur richtigen Zeit
kam mit der Entscheidung haben wir auch
eine politische Entscheidung im Raum ich
sage dass deswegen weil natürlich damit
nicht gesagt ist dass tatsächlich hier
eine
energiepolitische Entscheidung an die
noch anzuknüpfen wäre getroffen wurde
sondern einen Entscheidung womit wir mit
den verschiedenen Perspektiven die wir
in der Koalition nun mal in diesem Thema
haben zu einer gemeinsamen Lösung kommen
wollen und das betrifft jetzt einen
streckbetrieb und nichts weiter
es ist insofern wichtig dass noch mal zu
betonen weil natürlich alles weitere wie
zum Beispiel die Anschaffung neuer
Brennelemente überhaupt nicht vereinbar
wäre mit einer kostengünstigen
Energieversorgung mit einer
importunabhängigen Energieversorgung mit
einer den nachfolgenden Generationen
gerecht werdenden Energieversorgung es
wäre nicht damit vereinbaren das ist
auch Fakt der Word nuklear Report der
gerade wieder neu aufgelegt wurde hat es
auch noch mal belegt es ist auch Fakt
dass kein Atomkraftwerk weltweit kein
einziges
krisenresistent gebaut wurde kein
einziges und insofern ist es einfach ein
Himmelfahrtskommando weiter auf diese
höchst-risikoreiche Technologie zu
setzen die sich nicht verträgt mit
erneuerbaren Energien die erneuerbare
Energien im Netz blockiert und deswegen
haben wir auch richtigerweise jetzt
gerade erst vor ein paar Wochen
vor ein paar Wochen und besser heute
runterfahren widersprechen sie sich da
nicht vielleicht gerade mal weitersehen
also ersparen das ist ja schon
bemerkenswert jetzt höre ich gerade wenn
es wie wäre es nicht vernommen hat dann
lieber gleich runterfahren dann
entscheiden Sie sich mal sie
widersprechen sich da gerade aber wir
nehmen das gerne wir nehmen das gerne
mit deswegen haben wir ja auch vor
wenigen Wochen erst den erneuerbaren
Energien Booster beschlossen und mit
diesem erneuerbaren Energien Booster
wird zum Beispiel verstärkt die Nutzung
von Bioenergie ermöglicht alleine
Zugänge alleine diese Mengen blieb bis
Ende 2024 genutzt werden können alleine
diese Mengen werden errechnetermaßen
mehr bringen als die Mengen die jetzt
durch die drei AKWs durchstreckbetrieb
ermöglicht werden und wir haben die
Nachtabsenkung abgemildert für die
Windenergie wir haben Erleichterung für
ein paar und es werden noch viele
weitere Maßnahmen weiter noch
erschlossen werden können insofern sind
Sie herzlich jederzeit eingeladen aber
zum Schluss in der Energiewende der
erneuerbaren Energien liegt die
Ausweitung des energieangebots was sie
heute diskutiert waren vielen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion war das reagierte
hier kurz auf ihren Spahn der schon
gesprochen hat und aus seiner Fraktion
aus der Unionsfraktion spricht nun auch
Anja Weißgerber als nächstes sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen am 6 Juli
diesen Jahres habe ich hier in der
regierungsbefragung dem Bundeskanzler
die Frage gestellt warum nutzen Sie
nicht alle Optionen warum bremsen sie
die Biomasse aus und warum lassen sie
die drei Kernkraftwerke die
grundlastfähig und sicher am Netz sind
warum lassen sie die nicht weiterlaufen
darauf antwortete der Bundeskanzler
damals dass es bei den Kernkraftwerken
doch nur einen kleinen Teil der
Stromproduktion gehe und das Mantra der
Bundesregierung war über Monate hinweg
über Monate hinweg wir haben doch gar
keinen Stromproblem wir haben nur ein
wärmeproble meine Damen und Herren die
Menschen und Unternehmen die laufen
Sturm in unserem Land angesichts der
hohen Preise sie haben Angst vor einem
Blackout und die Experten die sagen sie
haben klar dargelegt dass das
Stromangebot ausgeweitet werden muss und
zwar mit allen Optionen die wir haben
die Realität hat doch die
Bundesregierung eingeholt genau dieses
ausweiten des Angebots das stellt dann
sicher unser
Energieversorgungssicherheit und das
dämpft auch den Preis je mehr
Kraftwerkskapazität im Netz ist desto
niedriger die Strompreise so auch zum
Beispiel die Aussage von Veronika Grimm
und was macht die Bundesregierung
bezüglich der Ausweitung dieses Angebots
sie entscheidet viel zu spät vor allem
mit Ankündigungen die dann auch noch
verschleppt und schlecht umgesetzt
werden ein Beispiel die Biomasse wir
haben immer wieder auch im Juli schon
beantragt dass der Biomasse Deckel der
die Nutzung der Biomasse einschränkt
aufgehoben wird immer wieder abgelehnt
worden hier im Deutschen Bundestag jetzt
ist er endlich aufgehoben worden die
Förderung der kleinen Wasserkraft sollte
abgeschafft werden sollte abgeschafft
werden auch da mussten wir sie wie man
bei uns in Franken sagt zum Jagen tragen
meine Damen und Herren das ist nicht das
was unser Land jetzt braucht meine Damen
und Herren
es Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers zur
Kernenergie greift viel zu kurz damit
löst er vielleicht ein Problem in der
Ampel aber nicht das Stromproblem in
unserem Land und sehr europäischen
Nachbarn liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die schütteln doch den Kopf über uns
merkte das eigentlich
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger der
Mittelstand des Handwerk alle erwarten
dass wir alles dafür tun dass die Preise
sinken dass wir die Energieknappheit
verhindern und zwar nicht nur in diesen
sondern auch im nächsten Winter ich sage
euch eines wenn der Bundeskanzler schon
des schärfste Schwert nutzt das er hat
nämlich jetzt die Richtlinienkompetenz
bemüht und davon Gebrauch gemacht dann
hätte ich erwartet dass er diese auch
richtig nutzt und nicht so halbherzig
meine Damen und Herren
auch die eigenen Experten der
Bundesregierung das ist ja so bezeichnen
die eigenen Experten der Bundesregierung
von der gaskommission sagen dass die
Energiekrise und die Knappheit von
Energie noch bis in den Winter 23 24
andauern wird die Herausforderungen
werden mindestens genauso groß wenn
nicht noch größer sein sagt die
gaskommission und die viel zu kurze
Laufzeitverlängerung die Kanzler Scholz
jetzt durchgesetzt hat die wirkt nicht
so Preis dämpfen wie sie wirken könnte
und sie gibt nicht die Antwort auf die
mögliche Energieknappheit im nächsten
Winter wir haben das Thema längere
Nutzung der Kernenergie seit März auf
die Tagesordnung gesetzt und haben jetzt
vor einigen Wochen einen eigenen
Gesetzentwurf entworfen wir haben eure
Arbeit gemacht ja und dieser
Gesetzentwurf der sieht vor dass die
Kernkraftwerke und zwar alle drei
Kernkraftwerke mit neuen Brennelementen
bis Ende 24
weiter genutzt werden können weil wir
brauchen diese Kernkraftwerke als Brücke
neben dem massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien das eine tun und
das andere nicht lassen es wird uns ja
immer unterstellt wir würden nicht den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren wollen in der
Fragestunde sind glaube ich in der
Aktuellen Stunde keine Fragen zugelassen
aber da ich schon weiß was die Kollegin
von den Grünen sagen und fragen will
kann ich auch gerne sagen dass wir in
Bayern an der Spitze stehen bezüglich
der erneuerbaren Energien
landesgruppenchef neulich gesagt das
einzige die einzige erneuerbare Energie
ist Wind am See und bei Wind an Land bei
Wind an Land stehen wir im Mittelfeld
stehen wir im Mittelfeld und noch vor
Baden Württemberg so und das ist die
Wahrheit es ist auch der absolute Hammer
des sage ich Ihnen dass das Parlament
das parlamentarische Verfahren gar nicht
im Gang gesetzt wurde es ist ein
schlechter Kollege ist die FDP hat sich
nicht durchgesetzt und versuchts als
Erfolg zum verkaufen das ist doch die
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren
so Anja Weißgerber war das hier noch mal
die Position der Unionsfraktion
[Musik]
Zwischenfragen die nicht genehmigt sind
in der Aktuellen Stunde da ist das nicht
vorgesehen ansonsten freue ich mich sie
alle frisch und munter zu sehen und gebe
offensichtlich das Wort und Katrin
Henneberger verbunden ist die bereits am
Rednerpult steht aber es gab einen
Wechsel das noch der Vollständigkeit
halber bei der Sitzungsleitung katrin
Göring-Eckardt die bundesvizepräsident
Bundestags Vizepräsidentin leitet jetzt
die Sitzung ab Rednerpult Kathrin
Henneberger für die Grünen der Rohstoffe
zu diskutieren Deutschland sowie andere
europäische Länder können sich leisten
auf dem internationalen Markt teure
Preise für Flüssigkeit aber auch für
Steinkohle bezahlen zu können damit
verringert sich natürlich auch das
Angebot für andere Länder die es sich
nicht leisten können die höheren Preise
zu bezahlen die Verknappung und die
höheren Preise beispielsweise von
lng-gas führen bereits zur
Stromausfällen und erhebliche Gefährdung
der Energiesicherheit in Ländern wie
Pakistan und Bangladesch die Auswirkung
des Angriffskrieges Russlands gegen die
Ukraine verschärft globale
Ungerechtigkeit verschärft Armut und
Hunger dieser Realität müssen wir uns in
Deutschland stellen und die
Verantwortung übernehmen Lösungen zu
erarbeiten und und die prekäre Situation
in den anderen Ländern nicht außer Acht
lassen das darf uns nicht egal sein
dafür werden wir Lösungen finden
Verantwortung übernehmen
die Lösung muss auch gleichzeitig
natürlich Antworten finden auf die
Herausforderungen der Klimakrise dass
wir global aussteigen müssen aus der
Verfolgung von Öl Gas Kohle und Atom aus
Sicherheitsgründen bedeutet dass wir
natürlich die Versorgung der Energien
komplett umstellen müssen auf
erneuerbare
ich finde es wahrlich gefährlich dass
hier im Bundestag disinformationen
verbreitet werden und versucht wird der
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zu behindern ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ich sehen
würde dass in Bayern mehr Windanlagen
erstellt worden wäre denn die
ausbremsung der erneuerbare Energiewende
in anderen Regionen führt dazu dass in
meiner Region der soziale Friede wieder
gefährdet ist danke für nichts
Atom ist aber auch keine Lösung für die
Zukunft koloniale Ausbeutung und
Ungerechtigkeit beginnt bei Atom bei den
uranenden Verletzungen von
Menschenrechte und massive Verseuchung
von Umwelt darf nicht die Grundlage sein
der Beginn unserer Energieversorgung
deshalb möchte ich auch die Forderung
nach neuen Brennstäben sehr klar
zurückweisen Atom ist und bleibt eine
Risikotechnologie ich weiß nicht ob sie
sich an Fukushima oder Tschernobyl
erinnern ich kann mich sehr wohl
erinnern an die Auswirkungen und wir
sollten wahrlich froh sein um jedes AKW
das auf der Welt vom Netz geht
wenn im nächsten Jahr erneut ein
Hitzesommer droht die durch die
Klimakrise nun mal normal werden auch in
unserer Region wird Frankreich erneut
massive kühlwasserprobleme für ihre AKWs
erhalten das ist wahrlich nicht der
einzige Grund warum wir die
Energieversorgung dass wir eine
Energieversorgung die Klimakrise nicht
ausklammern dürfen das Potsdamer
Institut für Klimafolgenforschung hat
erst vor kurzem vor der
drohnenüberschreitung der Kipppunkte in
unserem Klimasystem gewarnt ein
Kipppunkt ist beispielsweise das
grönländische Eisschild bei einem Punkt
ist dass ab einem Punkt wird es so sein
dass das Abschmelzen nicht mehr
aufzuhalten ist egal ob wir uns danach
dann entscheiden die Emissionen zu
reduzieren unsere Erde wird sich
aufgrund des verlorenen kühleffekts der
reflektierenden Eisschildes weiter
erhitzen
laut dem Pic besteht die Gefahr dass
dies sowie das Auftauchen der
permafausböden passiert und zwar bereits
bei dem der Zeit derzeitigen Stand der
globalen treibhausgaserhöhungen
unsere Energieversorgung ist untrennbar
verknüpft mit dem Aufhalten der
Klimakrise und das bedeutet nur eines
erstens massive Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien zweitens eine
energieeffizienzrevolution drittens
Maßnahmen und um die Energieeinsparungen
voranzubringen
um unsere Energieversorgung krisenfest
zu machen
benötigen wir aber auch eine Abkehr von
der Abhängigkeit großer Konzerne die
beinahe Pleite von uniper ist hier ein
konkretes Beispiel wir brauchen aber
auch politischen Handlungsspielraum bei
der Abschaltung von Kohlekraftwerken bis
Handlungsspielraum um beispielsweise
Kohlekraftwerke doch eher abzuschalten
aufgrund der Realität der Klimakrise und
damit wir unsere Klimaziele einhalten
die 1,5 Grad Grenze nicht überschreiten
damit
die Alternativen zu fossilen groß werden
und wir eine abgehaben von unbelehrbaren
kohlekonzernen sind erneuerbare im
BürgerInnen Hand die Lösung gut die
Hälfte unseres Stromverbrauchs deckt
bereits die erneuerbare Energien und
rund 50 Prozent der Anlagen sind immer
noch in BürgerInnen Hand das wollen wir
unterstützen weiter fördern und damit
die Grundlage legen für eine
klimagerechte und demokratische Zukunft
vielen Dank
Katrin Henneberger war das hier von der
Bündnis 90 grünen Fraktion ja sie hat
auch das Thema perennstäbe noch mal
angesprochen reichen die Brennstäbe nach
Angaben der drei Betreiber ist keine
Neubeschaffung von brennstreben nötig um
einen Weiterbetrieb nach dem 31 Dezember
zu ermöglichen das war ja auch eine
zentrale Forderung der Grünen Aktuellen
Stunde versammelt ich habe aufmerksam
gelauscht und festgestellt so richtig
aktuell war das alles nicht was hier
jetzt vorgetragen wurde von der
Opposition also diese reden habe ich
jetzt fünf sechs sieben Mal gehört
glaube ich aus Richtung der AFD manchmal
kannte ich schon ganze Sätze und Absätze
mindestens die Formulierungen sind mir
alle bekannt und ich möchte auch darauf
eingehen dass es so ein kleiner Tick von
mir obwohl sie immer das gleiche
erzählen und sich nicht an Fakten
orientieren versuche ich trotzdem immer
noch mal bei den Inhalten hinzuhören und
siehe da es
gerade bei den Erneuerbaren immer der
gleiche Angriff das ist vogelschredder
und ich habe dann mal zugehört in allen
anderen reden die ich hier im Parlament
so verfolgt habe wie oft Ihnen die Vögel
gerade in diesem Land eigentlich am
Herzen liegen und mir ist aufgefallen
genau null mal die Vögel in diesem Land
sie sind nicht ihr Herzensanliegen sie
sind immer nur da wenn es darum geht den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zu blockieren
meine Damen und Herren von der ganz
rechten so wird kein Schuh daraus sie
ziehen sich hilfsargumente heran wann
immer es ihnen passt und auch dass ihnen
die Stromversorgung in Pakistan am
Herzen liege das kaufe ich ehrlich
gesagt der Kollegin Henneberger von den
Grünen wesentlich mehr ab als ihnen weil
sie es zumindest regelmäßig vorträgt
und jetzt kommen wir also zur Aktualität
die erste der erste Teil der aktuellen
Ihrer Anmeldung den kann man ja
eigentlich gleich überspringen denn er
suggeriert nicht mal das ist Aktualität
geben würde es geht da ja um das wie die
Regierung diskutiert hat zum Thema
Kernkraft und auch bei dieser
titelanmeldung die ja sehr kurzfristig
erfolgt ist kann man also feststellen
sie setzen sich mit der Vergangenheit
auseinander sie setzen sich mit der
Vergangenheit auseinander das Gute an
dieser Regierung die dieses Land hat ist
wir diskutieren in der Gegenwart und wir
lösen die Probleme die wir in der nahen
Zukunft haben werden so werden Schuh
darauf und deswegen sorgen wir für
Energiesicherheit in diesem Land auch in
diesem Winter meine lieben Kolleginnen
und
und auch gerade diese aktuelle Stunde
hat eines gezeigt sie haben sich in
Probleme verliebt wir sorgen für die
Lösung dieser Probleme sie haben sich in
die Probleme regelrecht verliebt die
gaspeicher haben wir befüllt über das
ganze Jahr über 96% Füllstand erfolgt
dieser ampelregierung wenn wir das im
März nicht angegangen wären wenn wir den
unionsvorschlag gefolgt werden Nord
Stream 1 zuzumachen dann würden wir
jetzt nicht so gut gerüstet vor diesem
Winter stehen und die Realität sie gibt
uns Recht die Realität in diesem Land
gibt uns Recht schauen sich bitte die
Preise am Gas Spot-Markt an schauen sich
die Preise am Gas future Markt an
steigen sie schauen Sie sich die
sinkenden Preise am Strommarkt an sie
verlieben sich in Probleme weil sie
diese Probleme nutzen wollen um daraus
politisches kapitalzuschlagen wir lösen
die Probleme im Energiebereich dieses
Landes weil wir ein Interesse daran
haben dass dieses Land gut durch den
nächsten Winter kommt und dass die
Industrie und dass die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher in diesem Land gut durch
die nächsten Jahre kommen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir werden mit den Maßnahmen die wir
vor allem über dieses Jahr ja haben
machen müssen nicht stoppen wir haben in
diesem Jahr das größte EEG verhandelt
dass dieses Land je gesehen hat die
größte eeg-reform viele Vorschläge die
ja auch aus dem konstruktiveren Teil der
Opposition gekommen sind haben wir in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten umgesetzt
aber wir haben ja gerade erst begonnen
das eine ist ja der Kapazitätsausbau bei
den Erneuerbaren das andere ist dass wir
erstmalig eine speicherstrategie
vereinbart haben wir haben erstmalig
eine speicherstrategie für dieses Land
verantwortet zu Recht wird ja einmal
darauf hingewiesen reicht nicht nur die
Produktionskapazitäten auszubauen man
muss die Energie dann auch speichern ja
dann frage ich gerade die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union wenn doch
diese Erkenntnis auch in ihren Köpfen
schon Raum gewonnen hat warum dann nur
mussten wir überhaupt erst mal Speicher
im Gesetz definieren es gab sie bisher
gar nicht als eigene Definition kein
Wunder sie hatten keine
speicherstrategie wir räumen damit jetzt
auf damit die Erneuerbaren auch dann zur
Verfügung stehen wenn sie eben gerade
mal nicht so viel produzieren das ist
der missing link die Lücken zu schließen
wenn die Erneuerbaren nicht zur
Verfügung steht wenn sie das auch wollen
dann applaudieren sie jetzt heftig
vielen Dank herzlichen Dank meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
jetzt hat Marc Helfrich das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion er ist ja Sprecher für
Energiepolitik der cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen seit Februar leben wir in einer
neuen Realität seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine befindet
sich Deutschland in einer nie
dagewesenen Energiekrise gedrosselte und
ausbleibende gastlieferung und
explodierende Strom und Gaspreise über
all das diskutieren wir seit Februar und
seit Februar diskutieren wir in
Deutschland über die Notwendigkeit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der deutschen
Atomkraftwerke warum unsere AKWs weiter
betrieben werden müssen hat der
EU-Kommissar Breton für unsere
Nachbarländer auf den Punkt gebracht man
kann nicht sagen dass ich nicht das
mache was ich machen könnte aber erwarte
dass andere liefern was ich brauche
auch die fünf Wirtschaftsweisen fordern
die Atommeiler bis zum Ende der
Energiekrise weiter zu betreiben und
mehr als jeder Zweite in Deutschland ist
offen für einen Weiterbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke sogar über das Jahr
2024 hinaus und die Antwort des
Bundeskanzlers auf die Atomfrage
fahrlässig hat er die Debatte monatelang
laufen lassen statt zu führen begab er
sich ohne Not in die Geiselhaft der
Grünen die aus rein ideologischen
Gründen den Fortbetrieb der letzten drei
AKW blockieren
und das alles nur um den Gründungsmythos
der Grünen unangetastet zu lassen
diese ampelregierung ist durch den
Streit und die Atomkraft nach nicht
einmal einem Jahr massiv beschädigt
inmitten der größten Wirtschafts- und
Energiekrise ist diese Regierung uneinig
hilflos und nur bedingt handlungsfähig
noch am 11 August antwortet der
Bundeskanzler auf die Frage zu seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz es ist gut dass ich
sie habe aber natürlich nicht in der
Form dass ich jemanden einen Brief
schreibe
nun am Montag hat der Bundeskanzler
einen Brief geschrieben und seine
Richtlinienkompetenz ausgeübt findet den
Fehler
die Kernkraftwerke sollen jetzt bis
Mitte April nächsten Jahres weiterlaufen
aber wie souverän regiert der Kanzler
der nach gerade mal zehn Monaten im Amt
seinen drei Ministern in einem Brief
mitteilen muss was zu tun ist
wie steht es um die Autorität des
Kanzlers der mit der Ausübung der
Richtlinienkompetenz fast sein gesamtes
Pulver verschießt und was bedeutet das
eigentlich für die zukünftige
Handlungsfähigkeit dieses Kanzlers in
den letzten Jahrzehnten war die
öffentlich ausgeübte
Richtlinienkompetenz lediglich die
ultimative Drohung ich sage Ihnen das
kann ein Kanzler nur einmal machen
danach kommt nur noch die
Vertrauensfrage
Herr Scholz sie halten diese Regierung
nicht durch Führung auf Augenhöhe
zusammen sondern nur noch mit
Richtlinienkompetenz und das für
läpische dreieinhalb Monate
streckbetrieb mit ihrer späten
Entscheidung verringern sie gerade mal
das unmittelbare Risiko einer
Stromknappheit in diesem Winter mehr
nicht
längerfristig hilft uns das kein Stück
weiter denn sie unterlassen es
vorsätzlich jetzt neue Brennelemente zu
bestellen und wegen der langen
Lieferzeiten ist damit endgültig klar
wir haben im Winter
2023/24 noch weniger gesicherten Strom
zur Verfügung als in diesem Winter und
woher nehmen sie eigentlich die
Gewissheit dass die Energiekrise am 15
April 2023 endet
wir brauchen mindestens drei laufende
Kernkraftwerke bis Ende 2024 und sofort
neue Brennstäbe allein der Weiterbetrieb
von drei Kernkraftwerken senkt den
Strompreis und bis zu zwölf Prozent
die Ampel könnte übrigens noch etwas für
Bürger und Märkte tun uns endlich mal
darüber aufklären wie viel LNG aufgrund
verbindlicher liefer zu sagen eigentlich
nach Deutschland kommen wird auch das
ist ja für die Versorgungssicherheit
dieses Landes nicht ganz unwichtig meine
Damen und Herren wie gern wünschte ich
mir dass ich hier im Frühjahr stünde und
ihnen zum Abschluss sagen könnte nutzen
Sie die nächsten Monate um
Versorgungssicherheit zu schaffen jetzt
kann ich Ihnen nur noch zurufen winter
is coming
war das für die Unionsfraktion ja die
Argumente sind bekannt die
cdu/csu-fraktion die hat ja auch schon
vor einiger Zeit angesetzt Entwurf zur
Änderung des Atomgesetzes vorgelegt mit
dem die Fraktion die Berechtigung zum
Leistungsbetrieb für drei Atomkraftwerke
um mindestens zwei weitere Jahre bis
2024 verlängern will das ist übrigens
morgen auch Thema hier im Plenum des
Bundestages wenn dann über diesen
Gesetzentwurf der Unionsfraktion noch
mal debattiert wird jetzt letzte Redner
in dieser aktuellen Stunde für die SPD
Timon kremmels aktuelle Stunde ernst
nehmen würde würde sie sofort Anträge
einbringen zum Ausbau der Windkraft zum
Ausbau der Photovoltaik zum Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien all das ist die
Möglichkeit nein sie haben noch nicht
mal den Mut und die Ehrlichkeit die hier
hinzustellen und zu sagen sie möchten
eine Ausweitung des
fossil-atomarenangebote ist das ist das
was Sie wollen dann sagen Sie es auch
hier meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren so bringen sie Leute auf eine
falsche Fährte
aber ich sage Ihnen Herr Spahn das nehme
ich Ihnen auch persönlich ab dass sie
sich wörtlich und hier auch am redepult
von der AFD als Person auch distanziert
haben zu Recht aber dann wünsche ich mir
das auch mal ein Hinweis an ihre
Kollegin Julia Klöckner also ich finde
fand ihre tiraten gegen das
regenport-portal der Bundesregierung und
die geteilten Artikel von Tichys
Einblick ehrlich gesagt eine Bewegung in
Richtung rechts und das ist für die
Union als meiner Sicht sollte es eine
rote Linie dann eine schwarze Linie sein
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
das ist das ist aus meiner Sicht etwas
wenn man versucht der AFD nachzueiferner
bekommt man solche Ergebnisse wie sie in
Niedersachsen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren und wenn sie selber sich hier
hinstellen im Vorfeld der Wahl von
Niedersachsen und ausrufen wie das
Friedrich Merz getan hat die
Entscheidung der Wählerinnen und Wähler
am Sonntag in Niedersachsen ist auch
eine Volksabstimmung für die
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke über
2023 hinaus ja was ist denn aus dieser
Volksabstimmung geworden Herr Spahn
minus 5,5% das schlechteste Ergebnis wer
eine solche Volksabstimmung ausruft der
muss hinterher auch in den Ergebnissen
des Volkes umgehen können ersparen das
gehört auch zur Ehrlichkeit dazu
und wenn wenn er Parteivorsitzender
heute morgen im Deutschlandfunk sagt man
habe die Ausbauziele in der
Vergangenheit nicht erreicht und man
werde sie auch in Zukunft nicht reichen
erreichen weil die Ziele zu ambitioniert
sind das ist doch eine völlig falsche
Analyse warum haben wir denn die Ausbau
des Ziele unter ihrer Regierung nicht
erreicht weil sie auf der Bremse
gestanden haben es waren doch die
Kollegen die hier auf dieser das wissen
die doch selber Helfrich ich hatte sie
ja noch für einen der vernünftigen aber
auch an dieser Stelle können Sie mal die
Kollegen Pfeifer Köppen und Co Fragen
Nüsslein die standen doch alle auf der
Bremse deswegen sind wir nicht
weitergekommen und nicht weil die Ziele
zu ambitioniert waren sondern weil sie
hier war Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
haben sehr geehrter Herr Spahn
und ersparen wenn Sie uns jetzt zurufen
was machen wir denn im Winter dann
gucken Sie mal an was diese Koalition in
den letzten Wochen beschlossen hat und
ich würde auch mal medial die
pressevertreterin und die Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer hier auf der Tribüne
gucken sich nicht auf das eine Thema zu
fokussieren was natürlich sehr viel
einfacher zuzuspitzen ist sondern auch
mal genau hinzugucken was wir gemacht
haben wir haben zum Beispiel bei der
Photovoltaik das Potential für
Freiflächenanlagen im nächsten Jahr von
20 auf 100 Megawatt erhöht das ist ein
riesen potenzialerhöhung wir haben das
Thema Repowering auf den Weg gebracht
von 63 auf 100 Gigawatt Repowering auch
das wird kurzfristig dazu helfen weil zu
weil zum weil wir über diesen Winter
ersparen kommen wir doch auch deswegen
weil wir gesagt dieser Leistungen
getroffen haben und weil es jetzt noch
ein streckbetrieb geben wird es tun sie
geht es geht jetzt hier um den nächsten
lindern und wir werden hier das tun wir
werden auch das Repowering von photo
gezeigt wird dazu führen dass die
Potenziale deutlich steigen werden dass
sich zum Teil durch die neuen
Solarmodule einen Solarpark in der
Leistung verdoppeln kann meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und gerade
bei der Bioenergie Baugesetzbuch haben
wir geändert und die technischen
Potenziale bestehen darin dass man jetzt
auf insgesamt 19 Terawattstunden Gas bzw
7 Terabyte Stunden Strom das erhöhen
kann das ist etwas Konkretes das nutzen
wir genauso wie auch dass wir die
Nachtabschaltung für kürzt haben von
Windkraftanlagen genau das sind die
Maßnahmen die Potenziale bringen die uns
helfen werden dafür brauchen wir über
dem März hinaus des nächsten Jahres
keine Atomkraftwerke meine Damen und
Herren die Energiewende funktioniert mit
dem konsequenten Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
lassen sie mich zum Schluss
auch die Zeit nutzen noch etwas zu sagen
zum Thema
strompreisbremse bei allen Diskussionen
die wir derzeit führen und auch in
Zukunft führen werden dürfen wir das
Kind nicht mit badeausschütten ich bin
sehr dafür dass wir zufallsgewinne
abschöpfen über einem konsequent aber
wir müssen auch denen die wir jetzt in
der Energiewende brauchen nämlich die
Anbieter erneuerbare Energien brauchen
auch zukünftig noch genügend Kapital und
Invest um die Energiewende
voranzubringen also bei allem was wir in
den nächsten Wochen hier diskutieren
werden jawohl zur
zufallsgewinnabschöpfung aber so dass am
Ende des Tages die Unternehmen die wir
für die Energiewende brauchen auch noch
ihre Investitionen leisten können in
diesem Sinne alles Gute und Glück auf
danke schön
simon gremmels war das für die SPD
letzte Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
die beantragt wurde von der afd-fraktion
Kurse bis 16:30 dann klingelts und es
geht hier weiter mit
Gesundheitspolitik ja verehrte Zuschauer
sie haben es gehört der nächste Minister
der nämlich hier sozusagen am Zuge wäre
das wäre Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und der sitzt noch gar nicht
auf der Regierungsbank denn die Debatte
war auch erst ab 16 30 terminiert da
wird es gehen um die Entlassung der
Pflegekräfte aber diese kurze
Unterbrechung hier im Bundestag wollen
wir nutzen und Sie über weitere aktuelle
Geschehnisse informieren das macht meine
Kollegin Tina Dauster in Bonn ja vielen
Dank Jeanette Clark so ist es wir
schauen auf das was sonst heute noch im
politischen Berlin passiert ist heute
Vormittag hat das Bundeskabinett die
rechtliche Grundlage für einen
Weiterbetrieb der verbliebenen drei
deutschen Atomkraftwerke bis zum 15
April kommenden Jahres auf den Weg
gebracht und damit auch für die
Verschiebung des Atomausstiegs gestimmt